my miami marlins swept the cubs 2-0 in
the wild card round
game one of their nlds with the braves
begins tomorrow afternoon at two eastern
and their manager don mattingly joining
us on the program
donnie how's morale with the marlins
well it's pretty good dan i didn't know
you were on the bandwagon oh yeah
absolutely whenever you win i'm on the
bandwagon
i like it i like it um by the way who
gave you
donnie baseball as a nickname kirby
puckett we used to do a dinner
and here's how it got started we used to
do a dinner up in rochester every year
and
a lot of guys would go for ken kaiser uh
the umpire there was for
an orphanage up there and you know you
have the hospitality sweden guys were
just having fun and kirby's always like
baseball baseball dining baseball
baseball
baseball it just kind of stuck
and and and that's how for me that's how
i got started but did you ever feel
weird like teddy ball game for ted
williams but
did if like you weren't uncomfortable
with that nickname like yeah
i'm donnie baseball now for for a long
time when you're younger definitely
uncomfortable with it because of like
you said teddy ball game and guys like
that
but now i have i have a lot more fun
with it i tell guys i'm donnie effin
[Laughter]
you can say that as you win a playoff
round there after
after what happened at the start of the
season if i would have told you back
then
hey by the way you're going to go to
this at least the second round
and you're going to beat the cubs uh in
the wild card what would you have said
i i just said we you know what i think
we could do that
quite honestly um especially when it got
to the 60 i think the 162 we had a
belief in ourselves because of the
pitching
um you don't know if that holds up your
depth has to hold up over 160.
uh but with the 60 and the guys we
brought in with our pitching
and the guys that we had like right
behind them you felt like okay
we can we can stop some people if we can
put some runs on the board
we're going to be okay but how close did
you think
you were or your team was to maybe being
shut down
i think that got close you know
listening to michael hill
uh while we were in philadelphia and the
numbers just kept piling up
and you know at that point dan the
stories were coming out that our guys
were running all around atlanta
and it made it sound like our guys were
just being totally irresponsible
and you know we couldn't do anything
about it but it just wasn't true
and and you know it got going like it
doesn't in the world now it got a couple
of guys and that thing
flew through our clubhouse what you're
seeing in in
in nashville right now with the titans
you've seen it with the cardinals it
once it gets started uh when you're in a
clubhouse setting man you're close in
there
and and it just took off how often are
you tested
every day now it was every other day uh
but since we entered the bubble
uh it's been it's been every day do you
like the new format
i guess you do like the new format you
moved on to the second round here but
uh could you see this being permanent
where it's best to three
to start out i like the best of three i
think it's
it's more fair i could see it the
playoffs being expanded a little bit
maybe not to 16 but maybe a little bit
more than it
has been i kind of like this bubble
format at the end when you get down to
the elite eight or the final four
i guess that's tough with cities though
that once you know fans can be there
that would be tough
but this is kind of fun because you were
playing kind of same time every day
you play every day you don't have to
travel um
the the biggest problem is just being
away from your your family
and now that we're into this situation
uh if your family
quarantined they could come into this
how do you manage differently
this season as opposed to any other
season
a little more sense of urgency with the
60 game season and i told we told
our players that we told our players in
spring hey it's time to turn the corner
and that worriedness thing and we're
going to be playing pin it race baseball
i told them i'm going to manage
differently it's going to be trying to
win every game we can win
and that means sometimes pinch hitting
for guys you don't that they don't like
being pin [ __ ] for and
and pulling pictures a little bit quick
uh but you still have to manage
the length of even a 60 game so you just
can't blow your bullpen up every day
uh you still have to use some common
sense yeah that's what i wondered and
that's why i thought you know tampa and
the dodgers were the teams
that i was picking to play in the world
series i was looking at depth on these
pitching staffs because
at first i thought you're going to need
at least 12 pitchers
and then i realized you might need 15
pitchers at least being available to you
at some point here
is that what this has all come down to
that we talk about offense but this
short
this truncated season is about pitching
i i think it i mean there's been quite a
bit of offense i mean we're playing one
of the teams this round that's got a
really good offense but
i think when you get into these series
you know you've seen it in the
cincinnati braves series these guys are
good offensive teams but good pitching
you're
you're gonna see one and two and three
you're not seeing four and five
in the middle of the bullpen you're
going to see the back end guys and one
two three
and there's a lot of good pitching out
there so if you have that
you got a chance to be in every game i
look at these home runs and how far
they're going
donnie like acuna hit one like
497 like these are preposterous numbers
aren't they like
do you remember home runs back when you
guys played where you went
that like a 400 and you know 20 foot
shot was a bomb back then it felt like
not now yeah yeah there was a few guys
right you know you had big mac
and canseco and there was there's a few
guys out there that hit him a long way
but now there's a lot more guys doing it
i think the ball still feels like it
jumps
i think the players are stronger i i
honestly do i think the training is
better
uh so i think they're hitting balls
farther they're taking more chances they
don't ever cut their swing down
uh we've talked i think we've talked
about this before with the strikeouts
yeah uh it's you know it's guys pretty
much go for it a lot
and are trying to get the ball in the
air um
but you you mentioned at cuny he's a
special he's a special talent
and uh when he hits him he's got bat
speed galore when he catches them
they're going to go a long way
yeah i i just i wonder about that that
did you lift weights
back when you played a little
in the off season and that's when it was
just starting kind of the nautilus
time right so that really helped me
honestly
really hit the weights in the winter but
now guys do it kind of season long and
they keep up with the program pretty
good
i just think the diets are better the
training is better
um you know we want to rest them we try
to rest players now that's before there
was no
real rest you didn't think about that
now you want guys rested
and i think players probably take a
little better care of themselves than we
did
well what was the clubhouse spread like
when you played with the yankees as
as opposed to what it's like now for
these players
well this year is different because
we've been eating off a plat out of
plastic
the whole year yeah right no group stuff
um but in general it's it's a lot better
like
there's a chef in every clubhouse right
on the road
in a normal season so you guys are going
into the ballpark to get a good lunch
uh then they'll eat before the game
after the game uh you're gonna get three
good meals at the ballpark
and it's just totally different what did
you eat with the yankees
whatever the guy put out sometimes you
didn't want to eat
it you know maybe a piece of pizza every
once in a while you'd like it but there
just wasn't
like before a game it was a cold cut or
a candy bar there was no real food in
there
was there always beer in there pretty
much
pretty much there was always yeah that
obviously changed with some of the
things that happened with guys
going home after games and things like
that so there there was
and probably a good change because of
you know what goes on with with
guys in there ever have a beer before a
game
no never never did you believe what the
red sox were saying that they would
cowboy up and
you know do a shot before uh the world
series
kevin millar talks about that uh you
know what i kind of
that group seemed to be you know they
they may do it
right and you know probably if it wasn't
something that was silly
you know like it was every day in three
or four but if somebody just took one i
mean
two hours before the game i can't
believe they're going out there hammered
or anything like that
did you did you get a say in what the
uniforms look like
what do you think of the marlins
uniforms be honest now
no i i think guys like the black they
they i think there has to be some
changes because you can't really see the
the name and the number on it
uh we like the new logo for sure when
you see the old logo i think the guys
really like the new logo
uh in general it's it's change right and
when you're bringing in
you want to change what you believe in
how you do things you want
the perception change so you have to
change that
and i think derricks did everything
that's been based has been fan
you know participation what do you like
why the colors
you know uh so yeah they're fine
uh so yeah i think guys in general like
the new logo
uh what happened on august 16th
you tell me i don't know where you were
where are we at uh
the braves game you got you got you
yelled at the umpire some f-bombs in
there
did i did i use the f word yep you did
and it wasn't donnie f and baseball
by the way but but what happened here
you know it's funny i think about you
when i get thrown out
but you don't think about me during you
think about me after if you thought
about me during you wouldn't get thrown
out
i know it's funny because like mel
stodomies he'll be next to me he goes i
knew you're gonna go
i can tell i can tell and that one i was
kind of surprised because
i know i was kind of barking about the
zone but there's like
there's nobody in the ballpark who cares
right there's nobody well that's why we
could hear the f-bombs there's nobody in
the ballpark probably
and you know the magic words that you
did it on purpose right
no i didn't i did not i when i got
thrown out i was surprised and that's
i didn't say the magic words until after
i was thrown out
then i'm walking up there i'm like
whatever
yeah what does your wife say when she
sees that
she laughs she laughs she shows me the
videos or she
watches it and she laughs at it and
she'll like she'll like rate them so
like she'll send me videos
other ones uh and like i had people call
me on that one and
and they said oh that's one of your
that's in the top five and i'm like
it didn't feel like it right don't feel
like that
well you know compose yourself at least
for the first couple of games all right
i'm getting better i'm getting older
damn start i really calmed down what one
time this year
i know i know but who so you had
managers though
like billy martin he was strategic and
getting thrown out right
i don't i don't know he could do it in a
variety of ways it felt like
yeah he probably could and yeah when he
got fired up though he didn't
yeah he may have wanted to go like he
had somewhere to go
and he probably did yeah absolutely
i know one time he went him and mickey
but he got tossed and by the fifth he
was gone
wait he met up with mickey mantle and
they left the stadium
no yeah billy they did yeah
they were going yeah well i'm
sure it was it was a bar the question
was where they were going to i'm sure
after that
those are just different times you know
obviously
yeah but that's not something that's not
who you were
no no no no because you were boring
pretty much
yeah pretty much yeah try to you know
on the down low behind the scenes
[Laughter]
now you're done effing baseball um hey
congrats
what a wild ride uh this is you know
will be interesting there with the
braves that starts tomorrow afternoon at
2
eastern in minute maid park in houston
uh thanks again for joining us donnie
all right dan good to talk to you all
right don mattingly